[Music]  tonight five courageous men will brave  the elements and face man's greatest  fear on naked drunk and surrounded by  hot stones  welcome to stove island on this sacred  spot five brave naked men will put  everything on the line especially their  penises in the last 12 hours they've  stood in the hot hot Sun be fed hot hot  beer meanwhile these stoves have been  cranked to a crotch frying temperature  of 500 degrees  whoever can last an entire summer  without stumbling into a stove and  burning off their wiener wins 1 million  dollars and a shirt by these hot stoves  one thing they're thinking they don't  want to burn their dick off yeah I can  tell you one thing I am NOT going to  burn my dick off the clock starts  right now  [Applause]  I think that's a great show I think we  should have spent a little more money on  the bird that's the worst  okay flew right through some spiderwebs  oh yeah good good saves yeah firewood  there right through those spiderwebs all  right  you